nous vous en parlions déjà en début de
semaine d'initiatives solidaires d'un
propriétaire de camping à la ville aux
dames qui propose d'accueillir une
trentaine de réfugiés ukrainiens dansent
et mobile homes depuis mardi soir les
familles s'installent progressivement la
majorité arrive de région parisienne où
les structures sont saturées sur place
hélène chapelet
arthur victoria et leurs trois filles
font partie des 36 réfugiés accueillis
actuellement camping de la ville aux
dames ils ont quitté leur ville dniepr à
l'extrême est de l'ukraine quand les
bombardements russes ont commencé là-bas
arthur travailler dans le bâtiment quant
à victoria elle élevait leurs enfants
après quatre jours de route et 3000
kilomètres parcourus en voiture ils vont
pouvoir se reposer un peu dans ce
bungalow que l'état met à leur
disposition gratuitement
le voyage a été compliqué et et on a eu
peur mais aujourd'hui après un peu de
repos je me sens mieux mais j'ai
toujours peur pour ma famille qui est
toujours en ukraine et j'espère que mes
proches vont rester en vie
ce qu'on veut c'est que la guerre se
termine le plus vite possible on a les
et obéit la maman de ma femme c'est que
sa soeur et toute sa famille on n'a plus
peur pour nous mais on craint pour elle
même s'ils ont encore des difficultés à
imaginer leur vie en france arthur et
victoria vont pouvoir bénéficier de
l'aide de l'état compte tenu du contexte
les ressortissants ukrainiens n'ont pas
à faire les démarches pour obtenir le
statut de demandeur d'asile
les personnes qui arrivent du crès n'ont
pas à demander l'asile elle bénéficie
d'un mécanisme spécifique qui a été
déclenchée par l'union européenne qu'est
le mécanisme de protection temporaire
est donc ce qu'elle doit faire c'est
prendre rendez-vous en préfecture
remplir un formulaire on leur remettra
une autorisation provisoire de séjour
qui dure six mois et renouvelable
jusqu'à trois ans et qui va leur
permettre d'ouvrir un certain nombre de
droits le droit de travailler le droit à
l'assurance maladie le droit à une
allocation pour subvenir à leurs besoins
et puis avec les services de l'éducation
nationale on va aussi organiser la
scolarisation des enfants
arina et son chien çapa ne devrait pas
poser définitivement leurs valises à la
ville aux dames le camping n'est qu'une
étape un lieu de répit et d'orientation
le temps de faire le point sur les
besoins de la famille et de lui trouver
un logement social